I
Amnesty International is putting on an
event for three members of the Russian
feminist punk rock group called [ __ ]
riot this is a band of women they have
been imprisoned for freedom of
expression they went into a church they
put on an impromptu concert and they
dared to criticize President Putin can
you tell me why you came out here today
yes to support [ __ ] riot in their
efforts to bring basically free speech
to Russia well we're here today to
support human rights in Russia I believe
that Russia effectively had the coup
d'etat in a recent months because II
legitimately elected parliament and
illegitimate elected president
practically creating laws that diminish
and squash the existing Constitution
it's out of control over there in Russia
and you know weird solidarity with [ __ ]
riot gets here the United States we also
experienced our freedom of speech speech
suppressed but in a much more veiled way
I think it's really it's interesting how
blatant it is in Russia we're here to
show solidarity with [ __ ] riot to let
them know that it's so important for
artists to be able to express themselves
and to complain about a government
that's unfair without actually being
punished by the government for doing it
so we're here to do it for them since i
can't i'm here to support [ __ ] riot and
i am very inspired by their being so
courageous and I am from Russia myself
and I have been in jail myself in Russia
so I know what they're going strong can
you give an example of what you see as
the more Vale type of but still
restrictive speech here in the US
absolutely we had to get a permit for
this concert and I'm a huge proponent
for not getting permits because I think
applying and getting permits is the
suppression of free speech I don't think
it's considered free speech of people
the authorities tell you where when and
how you can express yourself sexism and
racism in every ISM is so subversive now
nothing's really obvious so it's just
the little things that keep us from
being treated as completely equal church
and state are being mixed essentially in
Russia at this point same as it is here
in the United States hi love America for
all of the opportunities America gave me
that I could come here and I could just
create and for all of the opportunities
that I got my education and being able
to create a business overnight just you
know submit the paper and it's just you
get approved do you think that this kind
of grassroots type thing can can do
anything tangible to help these women
our just the situation in Russia I think
it's very important to raise the
awareness of American public and call
our attention to the situation overseas
because no matter what we believe we're
leavin one planet and everything is
interconnected and I think what we are
doing here is very important you know
what I want for somehow a picture to get
back to them and for them to see a bunch
of random people they don't know in
Washington DC showing support and
solidarity by dressing just like them so
I think that's possible I think that
they can see us see a picture of us and
it's the most obvious way I could show
to say you know we're with you we know
already that the pressure is working
that President Putin himself has now
expressed a desire for leniency we don't
think he would have done that if it were
not for the international pressure in
the spotlight so we're going to keep the
heat on
you